for the parents say you're a single mom
or a single dad
um which is already like there's gonna
be some stress in that
how do you
help your kid to not develop this nice
guy syndrome
the best way i know to do that is
through modeling and and probably you're
aware of that that you you know if
you're yeah if your daughter sees you
doing certain things she'll probably
model it you know mostly they say for
example yes most most children that
smoke grow up seeing adults smoke or you
know most that develop drinking issues
saw adults that's not always the case
but our children model our behavior for
good and for bad
so
if we're going back to what i was
talking about of you filling your own
bucket up for example if your daughter
sees you consciously surrounding
yourself with lots of resources those
cooperative reciprocal relationships i
was talking about whereas you and your
friends as you and professionals that
you have in your life your doctor your
dentist your chiropractor your
accountant your co you know co-workers
and you are consciously
getting what you need to fill your
bucket from those resources as you also
give you and i right now have a
cooperative reciprocal relationship we
both agreed to be here we both assume
we'll get something of benefit out of
being here together and you know if
after we're said and done if either one
of us decided that wasn't worth the time
or investment we probably wouldn't do it
again but if both of us felt like hey
that was worthwhile that was beneficial
we would very definitely consider doing
that again that's what a cooperative
reciprocal relationship is so if your
daughter for example
sees you
spending time with your girlfriends
exercising eating healthy meditating
going for walks in the park laughing
having fun
surrounding yourself with goodness
that fills your life fills your bucket
then you're giving to her from the
overflow and she will then model those
same behaviors
a good a good model for this is
a guy named m scott peck wrote a book
called the road less traveled
it's probably 40 years old i've heard
it's the all-time best-selling self-help
book
and there's a whole chapter in there on
discipline i'm a whole section holds a
section on love
and he says love i'm going to paraphrase
it
is the giving to oneself or to another
in a way that promotes one's or
another's spiritual growth now he could
also just say
well be okay
and he says and i teach this in a lot of
my programs he he has this really cool
model that i've expanded on he says if
the if the parents are meeting their
needs in a timely judicious way filling
their own bucket up if they have healthy
differentiated relationship with each
other to where mom and dad aren't in
what i call an ownership fused
relationship which is you belong to me
therefore you should constantly fill my
bucket up because i feel so empty that's
how most of us do our intimate
relationships but if our partner is just
one more of our cooperative reciprocal
relationships just one of many bucket
fillers that we have in our life and
we're one for them as well
both mom and dad's buckets are going to
be filled
and then peck says if the parents can
then
take the time to pay attention to each
of their child's needs and respond to
their needs in timely and judicious ways
and i add consistent to that list
because i think consistency is a real
important key so if you as a mom are
filling your own bucket you're
surrounded with good resources to keep
your bucket full to keep you energized
you can then pay attention to you'll
have time to pay attention to your
daughter you'll see what her own
particular needs are in any given moment
you'll give to them in timely ways
you'll give to her in judicious ways and
as i'm sure you've already found out
giving judiciously to our children
requires the wisdom of solomon you know
you know do you give your 11 year old
wait till she's it'll probably come
before 11. it'll probably happen at nine
maybe it's already happened she comes
home and says mom i need an iphone you
know i you know i need an iphone
yeah uh so i need an iphone and you know
your 11 year old doesn't need an iphone
because it's probably not good for her
to have an iphone but maybe every one of
her friends has an iphone and you don't
want her to feel left out and not apart
and oh what do you do with that i mean
those are
it seems like a not that important
decision but those are the important
decisions of judicious giving to your
children so so you if you if you're
giving to your child judiciously and
consistently peck says that a child
internalizes at the emotional level so
we're going back to talking about our
emotional internalization our emotional
operating system the child will
internalize i am important i'm lovable
i'm valuable that's number one number
two my needs are important and number
three that the world is like my family
now
if that doesn't happen if children don't
get their needs met in timely judicious
way they internalize the opposite i'm
not i'm not lovable valuable or
important my needs are not important and
the world is like my family so they're
going to go out into the world treating
interacting with the world like nobody's
going to love me or meet my needs unless
i like give to them first or you know
use whatever my survival mechanism is
but there's one more
internal belief system that children
develop if their parents are not doing a
very effective job of meeting their own
needs and then giving to the child in
time to judicious consistent ways often
a parent will use the child to come meet
some of their needs emotional needs
social needs needs for physical
connection and when a child is used to
meet a parent's need it's called
parentification
the child child will always believe
that they're not good enough because
remember children are
grandiose and and narcissistic and
egotistical if mom is sad and leaning on
their child the child thinks i should
make mom not sad but because mom is sad
and sad in ways that a child can't fix
and continues to be sad the child
internalizes i'm not good enough i can't
make mom be not sad i can't make dad not
be angry so the child also develops that
fourth belief system i'm not good enough
and then goes out into the world and
interacts with the world thinking i'm
not valuable i'm not lovable my knees
aren't important and i'm not good enough
but going back to your question if
you've been consistently
judiciously timely meeting your
daughter's needs not perfectly by any
means but just you know shooting for you
know being good enough your child will
internalize the belief system i'm
valuable i'm important my needs are
important as i go out into the worlds i
go to preschools i go to kindergartens i
go to schools i start dating in junior
highs i you know
on and on i'm going to believe that i'm
valuable my needs are important and the
world is going to respond in kind
and i don't know about you but i i think
about that at times what would it have
been like to been in junior high
thinking i'm valuable i'm lovable my
needs are important and everybody else
recognizes that
i'm thinking how how powerful that would
be and so that's how you how we raise
our children to develop this
internalized system where they don't
have to be using their defense
mechanisms their survival mechanisms
their covert contracts now we're not
going to get it perfect none of us do we
all had imperfect parents we're going to
be imperfect parents we're going to
raise imperfect children and in fact
giving yourself permission to be an
imperfect parent and letting your child
be an imperfect child it's one of the
greatest gifts that you can give them
because i see a lot of parents nowadays
wanting their children to be perfect so
they can feel like perfect parents these
helicopter parents that go you're going
to study this you're going to go to this
camp in this camp in this camp you're
going to make these grades and you're
going to go to this kind of college you
know that helicopter parent that's a
burden on a child it doesn't let the
child differentiate and just be who they
are
maybe the child just wants to be an
artist or play music or travel the world
but no you're going to get into mit
you're going to get into stanford you're
going to make the good enough grades to
get that that creates also that belief
in children that they're not good enough
and they've got to be perfect to be
loved
so letting your child be their imperfect
self is also a great gift to give your
child you raise your kid thinking and
i'm not going to be doing this but if
you do raise your kid and they end up
thinking they're not good enough does
that
lead to individuals who try and be
better and are more motivated and end up
being more successful
well it depends on our definition of
success okay
not happy like maybe from the outside
looking successful yeah and that's a
good question and of course we can look
around and see that and maybe we see it
in ourselves is that yeah there's a part
of me that wants to
achieve a certain degree of success so
that you know i can feel good about
myself and people will value me and
there there's there's a difference and
and i think the difference is is you
just have to feel the difference
um for example i got a phd at 29 years
old
and i think i was motivated number one i
almost dropped out of high school high
school just bored me i was just totally
lost and unarrested once i quit playing
sports i lost interest
and luckily i i i got with some really
good teachers i got into debate and and
got into some stuff that energized me
then all of a sudden you know studying
and making good grades
felt felt
just internal it felt interesting i
wanted to apply myself now
you could try to make grades trying to
get my good grades by trying to look
good or get approval or validation or by
time i got to college then and through
college and then to graduate school
i maintained about a 3.8 grade point
average and i think there was some part
of me that was yeah look at me i made
these kind of grades but not not a very
big part of me most of it just was i can
do this this feels good and that's what
that's the difference of how it feels
and where i'm at in life right now i'm
65 years old most people start like
thinking about retiring at my age i have
no interest in retiring and i don't know
what that would look like i'd still get
them do what i do um
and i i got i got nothing else that i
have to prove to anybody or accomplish
and so i'm purely motivated by the love
of doing what i do
it just it just excites me i mean just
two experiences that you know before you
and i started your call your your
producer said robert i read your book it
was really powerful at an important time
in my life i said thank you for telling
me that that feels good right that that
that my ego isn't built on that but it
feel good knowing that i made a
difference and it felt good when i heard
adam lane smith somebody that i don't
know personally say a really nice thing
about me on your podcast i thought i i
had to turn the podcast off and just sit
with it and just sit with it and think
that that was so out of left field i
didn't see that coming and it just
because i didn't and i just thought wow
that felt really good now
i don't do what i do to try to keep
getting that you know those nice words
and nice things i do what i do because i
love what what i do
and i'm glad that it makes a difference
and has an impact on people's life so
for example with you and your daughter
you could try well i'm going to do this
and do this and then she'll be a happy
child and i'll i'll look like a good
parent and i'll you know blah blah blah
and and that that's that external
validation kind of thing that's driven
from not feeling good enough inside
but if you just enjoy
the experience of being a mother with
your daughter and just love to death
just being a mom with her
then you're just going to be you it's
going to feel good it's going to feel
natural you're going to make mistakes
you're going to snap at her occasionally
you're going to let her hear things you
didn't wish he didn't hear
but you know what it's okay because you
know you know you're open-hearted and
loving towards her it just feels
different than that feeling of my
child's got to get good grades she's got
to look good she's got to make a good
impression she's got to make me look
like a good mom it just feels different
and and you can just check inside to
feel the difference in it
yeah